I had an argument with a dude like a
friend of mine who's a prominent guy in
the anti-max world and I said listen
brother
they didn't take your freedom this time
they already had it when you butchered
one million Iraqis a country that had
nothing to do with 9 11. they already
got your freedom when they sent you to
Afghanistan they already got your
freedom right when they had you bomb
Libya and open a slave market there they
already got your freedom what they
wanted now with this was something
totally different they didn't need to
put a microchip in the vaccine you
already got the micro chips and you're
walking around with this it's in your
pocket that's what's on everybody what
they did do
is that exposed something even crazier
that Adam Smith and Karl Marx even
though they're diametrically opposed
sides of Communism and capitalism were
both right there's only two classes the
middle class is a farce right and that's
what covid taught you because you could
be have a nice house Kev you have a nice
car a job but you're worth negative six
hundred thousand dollars and a lot of
you lost your homes during that time and
you realized oh no there are only two
classes there's the working class and
they're the people who control the means
of production and if you're not one of
these two people
then you think you're one in the middle
you're not really one in the middle
you're here see these people know who
the [ __ ] they are they don't pay taxes
their corporation doesn't pay taxes if
people want to look up any example of
that there's a famous woman from New
York called Leona Helmsley who owned the
Helmsley building and she got in trouble
because for years she paid no taxes like
all major corporations yeah I mean
Google doesn't pay I mean none of these
people pay taxes but she went out and
said in the media in the New York Times
only little people pay taxes and they
had to get her because this is such a
[ __ ] uproar in New York they were
like little people like you mean Working
Class People because a capitalist system
creates food and shelter as Commodities
so you're forced to work a 40-hour work
week instead of venturing to things you
would possibly like the fact that look
if I get
a a an album done and I pay the record
label back in a traditional scenario I
don't even keep the intellectual
property
it's crazy if I if I get a bank alone
for anything else and I pay the loan
back you get I own the car it's your car
is mine everything the problem is this
now people bring up is the house really
yours because if you don't pay those
property taxes that equal the equivalent
of the house payment take 50 years they
take the house do you ever stop paying
for it also like how many people
actually finish the 30-year mortgage
before they they move on to the next
thing
it's like ever it's like a rotation of
of [ __ ] for sure man